amid a lot of fanfare today freshman
Democrat Alexander Acacio Cortez joined
with Massachusetts Democrat Senator Ed
Markey to roll out ambitious plans for
democratic policy but even before it
launched the most powerful member of the
House downplayed the green New Deal and
after well a lot of people many in her
own party we're having to dodge
questions about the plans specifics the
reason many lawmakers find it pretty
far-fetched to eliminate flatulating
cows and air travel in just ten years
time chief congressional correspondent
Mike Emanuel joins us from Capitol Hill
with the green New Deal fallout good
evening Mike Bret good evening to you it
was stunning how quickly some Democrats
jumped on this proposal eager to link
themselves to the left star the moment I
am so incredibly excited the green New
Deal has an estimated price tag of seven
trillion dollars but it's freshman
champion congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez doesn't want to talk about that
the resolution does not have which is
why it is certainly ambitious moving
America to 100% clean and renewable
energy by 2030 through major investment
increases in wind and solar power
sweetened with generous tax incentives
and it would modernize US infrastructure
upgrade or replace every building for
energy efficiency and create an economic
safety net for low-income communities
but in trying to achieve those Net Zero
emission goals organizers are trying to
get a handle on practical limits
admitting in earlier drafts that quote
we aren't sure that we'll be able to
fully get rid of farting cows and
airplanes that fast that odorous
description was omitted from the
eventual online version but the plan
extends beyond the environment
guaranteeing job security and paid
vacation and it promises economic
security for all those who are unable or
even unwilling to work so when our
default is renewable when our default
investments are clean then
then all of us by default regardless of
income will have access to to those
energy sources some 20 20 presidential
hopefuls were quick to jump on board
including senators Elizabeth Warren
Kamala Harris Kirsten Gillibrand and
Cory Booker they used words like bold
and excited in supporting the resolution
but House Speaker Nancy Pelosi in an
interview with Politico referred to it
as the green dream or whatever they call
it nobody knows what it is but they're
for it right quite frankly I haven't
seen it but I do know that it's
enthusiastic and we welcome all the
enthusiasm that are out there Ocasio
Cortes didn't take offense when asked
about no I think it is a green dream I
don't consider that to be a dismissive
term I think it's a great term and it
has earned the seal of approval from
former Vice President Al Gore who called
the goals ambitious and comprehensive
many veteran Democrats with years of
experience on this issue seemed quite
content to let the newly elected New
Yorker take the rhetorical lead on the
plan Pelosi also rolled out her climate
select committee today and Ocasio Cortez
is not a member Ocasio Cortez insists
she was not snubbed Brett Michael Manuel
live on the hill Mike thanks